[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal préparé par la rédaction de tv à
60,18 nous sommes le mercredi 17 octobre
tout de suite les titres de cette
édition un renouveau entamé il ya un an
skywest cherche à se réinventer après
des temps difficiles
le centre commercial saint quentinois
poursuit le déploiement de sa nouvelle
offre axée sur les loisirs la culture le
sport et la restauration
où en est le projet nous faisons le
point il a accueilli les beatles ou
encore edith piaf l'oci et le cyrano
cinéma mythique de versailles mais qui
peinait récemment attiré les spectateurs
pour relancer la fréquentation le lieu
va faire l'objet d'une réhabilitation
le cyrano passera notamment de huit à
douze salles et puis une chef américaine
en tournée en france elle a été conviée
par sodexo pour parcourir les différents
sites du groupe en un mois première
étape cette semaine au siège de
l'entreprise à aiguille en cours et deux
invités également à suivre dans ce
journal david pennequin candidat sans
étiquette à l'élection municipale
partielle à coignières le 25 novembre et
2 décembre et anne capio maire-adjointe
d'elancourt pour parler de la codp week
c'est une semaine est dédiée au codage
informatique il ya tout juste un an le
centre commercial à skywest débutait son
renouveau ambition affichée attirer de
nouvelles enseignes fin 2017 c'était le
cas par exemple avec l'ouverture de la
librairie le furet du nord
ce projet est axé sur le loisir et la
culture notamment il est entré
aujourd'hui dans une étape
supplémentaire on fait le point sur le
projet avec mélanie poquet de nouveaux
arrivants après un pabx et restaurants
mois de septembre c'est un burger
stakhovsky a pris ses quartiers à
skywest ce concept italien est arrivé au
début du mois d'octobre les cibles de
oulu à la baisse c'est dans les centres
dans les grands centres commerciaux pour
réunion s'est indigné autour de la
famille toujours près des cinémas de
nouvelles arrivées à l'image d'un
renouveau pour le centre commercial
depuis 2015 et son rachat par le groupe
hammerson également propriétaire de
l'espace saint quentin skywest glisse
vers le loisir et la culture
le furet du nord est la première
enseigne à s'installer en octobre 2017
l'orientation qu'on a souhaité donner à
skywest est défini selon la
complémentarité que nous avons voulu
avec espace 50 ans espace saint quentin
le centre historique qui est plutôt une
destination de shopping
donc on a souhaité compléter cette
destination de shopping avec une
destination loisirs et culture et la
phase 3 qui se verra à partir de début
2010 neuf et qui complétera le projet
avec l'arrivée des oueds aucune en
scènes de simulation de voitures de
formule 1 sur vérins une salle de sport
sur 1300 m² est il notre enseigne de
divertissement avec laquelle nous sommes
en échange actuellement et chaque année
les centres skywest et espace saint
quentin accueille environ 15 millions de
visiteurs avec ces nouvelles ouvertures
la direction vise les 20 millions
le centre commercial sqy ouest qui
accueille mardi prochain une
avant-première le cinéma ugc proposent
une projection à 18h45 et du film de
gilles lellouche le grand bain avec la
présence d'une partie de l'équipe est le
grand bain avec les yvelinois guillaume
canet et alban ivanov l'histoire de huit
hommes qui se lancent dans la natation
synchronisée
une idée plutôt bizarre mais qui va
permettre à ces hommes de donner un
nouveau sens à leur vie
extraits voilà voilà on l affaire sur
kde musicaux et chorégraphiques
cette équipe de france avant première du
film le grand bain ce mardi 23 octobre à
18h45 à l'ugc skywest ce cinéma de
versailles est bien connue des yvelinois
le cyrano va faire peau neuve pour
relancer sa fréquentation est les
premiers travaux de la salle mythique
débuteront en 2019 les détails avec ce
sujet de patrick jacques de dixmude et
manon varaldo
[Musique]
à l'image des beatles edith piaf charles
aznavour johnny hallyday nombreux sont
ceux à s'être produit pour la première
fois en france sur la scène du cirano
mais le cinéma a perdu de nombreux
spectateurs des entrées pratiquement
divisé par deux depuis une vingtaine
d'années pour préserver ce lieu mythique
la ville de versailles travaillent en
collaboration avec ugc le but restaurer
entièrement la salle d' historique
c'est un projet très important pour nous
parce que c'est un cinéma au centre
ville et vous savez aujourd'hui on parle
beaucoup la désertification des
centres-villes et pour nous depuis dix
ans que je suis maire c'est vraiment
avec mon équipe
un combat c'est soutenir à l'activité de
nos commerçants nos mille six cents
commerçants qui reste encore en
centre-ville de versailles c'est une
reconstruction totale qui s'engage pour
le cirano il passera de 8 à 12 salles 10
seront accessibles pour les personnes à
mobilité réduite
un investissement important c'est un
investissement de l'ordre de 9 millions
d'euros
c'est donc un investissement stratégique
parce qu'il s'inscrit dans cette logique
de maillage et de proximité
nous pensons que aujourd'hui les gens
aux besoins d'accessibilité de proximité
et de lieux très qualitatif
le cera ne retrouvera son entrée
historique celle de l'époque des
concerts après les travaux l'accès se
fera de nouveau par la rue rameau on
aime cette idée de cinéma de quartier
parce que c'est son os et son identité
moi ce que j'aime c'est quand on a des
parents qui viennent avec leurs enfants
avec les parents disent c'est mon cinéma
c'est l'objet en juin depuis que je suis
tout petit quand j'ai des réalisateurs
comme eric toledano comme guillaume
canet qui me disent si menez cinéma je
viens là depuis je suis tout petit
l'ouverture au public du nouveau cyrano
est prévue pour fin 2020 un dernier mot
de cinéma avec le retour de nos petites
visites dans les salles la
saint-quentinoise pour découvrir les
films à l'affiché direction ce soir le
grenier à sel à trappes del pino nous
présente la programmation pendant les
vacances de la toussaint
c'est au micro de patrick jacques de
dixmude
[Musique]
bonjour je vais vous parler des films
que nous aurons au grenier à sel pour
les vacances puisque ça commence très
bientôt nous avons pour commencer la
chasse à l'ours la chasse à l'ours est
un film d'animation que l'on peut voir à
partir de 4 5 6 ans puisque c'est tiré
d'un livre jeunesse et qui est assez
connu une très belle comptines qui
restent dans la tête des enfants
elle était ce un ton très beau et un
beau une beau dessin pastel
nous avons aussi harry potter qui
revient sur les écrans ce n'est pas un
nouveau film ce sont les anciens films
qui sont gros numérisés restauré en
version 4 carats ultra hd donc pour re
pour qu'une nouvelle génération
d'enfants et d'adultes viennent voir
découvrez-les potter sur grand écran
vous les verrez cette pendant les
vacances nous avons aussi pour
diversifier pour les enfants un peu plus
grands à la 2 qui est la suite de aladin
donc la cave adams qui cette fois va
affronter jamel debbouze qui est un
vilain et nous proposons aussi dit lily
à paris le dernier film de michel ocelot
michel ocelot c'est quand même le papa
de kirikou qui va bientôt avoir 20 ans
d'ailleurs jeudi entre parenthèses donc
vous pouvez découvrir dix lits à paris
très joli film très belle animation
douze jeunes kanak à paris qui va avoir
qu'il y avait plein aventures des
enquêtes etc et pour les encore plus
grands il y a
des séances de sailor voice qui est un
film d'animation japonais vous retrouve
évidemment toutes les informations sur
notre site internet
sylvain grenier à sel points comme je
vous dis à bientôt transport de
nouvelles passerelles pour la guerre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines elles seront
mises en service en 2023 pour faciliter
l'accès aux quais une opération des
saturations présenté par ile-de-france
mobilité pour faire face à l'afflux de
voyageurs aux heures de pointe ils sont
soixante dix mille chaque jour à passer
par la gare située à montigny le
bretonneux travaux dans l'optique des
jo-2000 24 avec de nombreux visiteurs
qui devraient venir à saint quentin en
yvelines qui accueille des épreuves
montant total du chantier est de 12
millions et demi d'euros
elle a été rendue nécessaire après la
démission du maire et de plusieurs élus
une élection municipale partielle va se
tenir le dimanche 25 novembre un
éventuel deuxième tour elle le dimanche
de décembre nous allons recevoir sur ce
plateau les candidats au scrutin
le premier ce soir à se prêter à
l'exercice et david pelletier bonsoir
pensant à vous de m'avoir invité
merci de votre présence vous êtes
l'actuel 4e adjoint de la commune en
charge notamment des finances et vous
conduirez aux côtés de dominique
cathelain une liste sans étiquette agir
ensemble pourquoi nuire à l'enfant avant
de parler de cette candidature quel
regard vous portez sur le mandat de
jean-pierre sevestre on rappelle qu'il
était maire depuis 2015 il a démissionné
récemment de de ce poste de maire alors
moi faut savoir que j'étais conseiller
municipal et je ne suis que le 4e
adjoint que depuis un peu moins d'un an
je pense piste est difficile de
reprendre derrière henry bayeux qui
était là depuis de nombreuses années
jean-pierre sevestre connaissait bien la
mairie de coignières puisqu'il a été il
était depuis longtemps adjoint
c'était difficile il fallait aussi gérer
l'arrivée
dans l'agglomération de 50 ans qui est
un gros bouleversement pour pourquoi
venir qui est inquiète un petit village
et donc c'était un mandat de mise en
place avec l'entrée dans l'agglo
qu'était qui était pas facile à gérer
je pense qu'il a bien réussi l'entrée
l'entrée dans saint quentin puisque bon
malgré que nous soyons la plus petite
commune nous avions deux représentants
très actif avec des délégations sur sur
50 ans donc voilà après d'un point de
vue municipal on a été comme toutes les
communes soumis aux baisses de dotations
de l'état en l'occurrence pour
coignières il s'agit même plus de
dotations puisque la ville de coignières
ne reçoit plus de l'argent de l'état
c'est elle qu'on donne on a une dgf qui
est négative ce qui a obligé évidemment
à revoir un petit peu tout notre
fonctionnement
nous avons beaucoup de service public
rendu aux poignets rien il était
impératif de maintenir ce niveau de
service mais avec une baisse une baisse
des dotations il fallait imaginer des
nouvelles pistes re voilà et il y en a
une qui a voulu être étudié par par
jean-pierre seul est qui et qui est l'un
des sujets de la possibilité de communes
nouvelles classes de nouvelles commandes
nouvelles
on sait d'ailleurs de là que sont nés
quelques quelques polémiques et qui ont
scindé la majorité dont vous faites
partie en deux clans est ce qui a motivé
en partie le départ exactement et et
pourtant il ne s'agissait à ce moment là
que d'études pour voir s'il était
intéressant ou non de partir dans cette
idée là
j'ai repris en mai la délégation suite à
l'état de santé de jean pierre s'est
assuré l'intérim pendant un mois
2 j'ai pris mes responsabilités en tant
qu'élu la population ne souhaitait pas
poursuivre sur cette voie
j'avais donc acté l'abandon de la bande
à cette piste et nous nous sommes
concentrés ensuite sur d'autres pistes
pour réduire nos dépenses et pouvoir
maintenir un haut niveau de service
public à coignières qu'est ce qui vous
motive aujourd'hui à vous présenter à
cette municipale partielle
je pense qu'il ya encore énormément de
choses à faire sur coignières
c'est c'est une ville qui a quand même
beaucoup beaucoup de retard dans sa
modernisation notamment sur le sur le
numérique on voit aujourd'hui que nos
différents services travaillent avec des
outils qui ne sont plus les outils
aujourd'hui
et je pense qu'il faut il faut il ya
beaucoup de choses à moderniser on a
aussi énormément de travail à faire sur
nos bâtiments publics
beaucoup ont 20 30 ans et ont besoin
d'être complètement réhabilité je pense
aux écoles je pense qu aux
établissements sportifs
voilà il faut mener ses projets et puis
on est un tournant je pense de la delà
de la situation de coignières cognard a
été dans les années 80 connu partout en
france pour ses commerces et c'était
c'était une zone très très attractive
aujourd'hui on le sait le commerce a
changé les gens vont plus sur internet
ou en plus demandés dans des dents des
grands centres commerciaux qui regroupe
1 tad enseigne donc il ya une mutation
qui est en train de se faire et c'est
une mutation qu'il faut accompagner
il ya des pistes on peut devenir le
numéro 1 de l'innovation
voilà il ya des pistes à des pistes
nouvelles à mettre en place et je pense
que ça c'est la politique la politique
de la ville qui peut permettre de faire
ce tournant et puis la dernière chose
c'est parce que je l' ai vécu en tant qu
adjoint aux finances
autant la baisse des dotations qui
nécessitent d'être beaucoup plus
inventifs dans nos dépenses et dans
notre fonctionnement
et puis et puis 7-7 poursuite dans
l'agglomération ou même en étant le plus
petit je pense qu'on peut avoir une
place très importante et être peut-être
un moteur est un exemple en termes de
modernité de développement durable
puisque c'est une partie importante du
programme que propose notre liste lui
aussi est un gros enjeu david pelletier
s'est calmé on en parlait tout à l'heure
des ces polémiques qui ont enflé depuis
le projet de fusion avortée avec
maurepas qui ont créé une scission au
sein de la majorité entre les époux
rideaux et les contres à ce projet est
ce que ça sera possible de calmer ces
tensions
en tout cas nous on va pas s'occuper des
polémiques les polémiques on
les laisse à ceux qui veulent refuser le
débat d'idées nous on a un projet pour
coignard et pour les poignées rien et
c'est là dessus qu'on est concentré
quel est le projet vous vous en parliez
alors il ya trois priorités vous est
fixé trois priorités c'est ça la
modernité la solidarité parce que c'est
quelque chose de très important pour
coignières que ça soit aujourd'hui sur
sur la petite enfance l'enfance mais
aussi au profit de nos aînés voilà c'est
continuer c'est continuer sur ces voiles
à travailler beaucoup plus sur la
jeunesse qui est qui est un secteur
qu'on a un petit peu abandonnée depuis
depuis plusieurs mandats et sur lequel
il ya énormément de choses à faire et
notamment l'emploi
aujourd'hui à 12 % de chômeurs à
coignières alors qu'on a
près d'un millier d'entreprises c'est
pas une situation qui est acceptable et
donc il faut travailler sur sur l'emploi
des jeunes il faut les aider les
accompagner leur donner des moyens donc
donc voilà et puis et puis le dernier
le dernier point qui est important aussi
qu'en tant qu'élu j'ai tiré les leçons
de ce qui s'est passé avec ce projet de
communes nouvelles et
et on veut apporter beaucoup beaucoup
plus de gouvernance citoyenne beaucoup
plus gouverner décidé avec les habitants
au travers de comités consultatifs de
réunions publiques mais aussi d'appel à
projet en donnant des budgets aux
habitants pour porter des projets qui
qui les motive
donc voilà c'est c'est de travailler
vraiment ensemble pour le développement
et l'avenir de quoi dire un mot rapide
nous reste très peu de temps sur la
liste qui sera telle qu'on compose et on
sait qui a dominé 4-1 à vos côtés
première adjointe actuelle à coignières
qui assure qui assure la mairie voilà
une d'intérim qui sera sur cette liste
la liste la liste
est en train de se constituer elle est
alors elle est bien avancé m mais il ya
très peu de personne de l'ancienne
majorité
non ce n'est pas la continuité de
l'ancienne équipe majoritaire nous nous
avons un nouveau projet nous ne
remettons pas sur la table projet de
et puis c'est une liste qui est très
ouverte avec beaucoup de quoi ni rien
d'origine d'origines et d'horizons
différentes parce qu'on veut justement
avoir cette gouvernance cette
gouvernance citoyenne et on a beaucoup
de gens qui qui qui nous qui veulent
nous rejoindre aujourd'hui et ils
peuvent continuer à le faire apporter
leur pierre à l'édifice de notre projet
en nous contactant notamment par notre
site internet à un pc point fr merci
david pelletier d'avoir été avec nous je
rappelle que vous êtes candidat cette
municipale partielle à coignières
premier tour le dimanche 25 novembre et
un éventuel deuxième tour le 2 décembre
et vous conduirez à la liste sans
étiquette agir ensemble pour coignières
c'est une première en ile-de-france
l'installation d'une unité de traitement
des produits métalliques par décapage
grâce à cette technique le site gde de
limay va pouvoir décontaminer des métaux
grâce à l'eau à très forte pression un
avis d'un investissement de 500 mille
euros pour l'entreprise un reportage de
nicolas landry des pièces métalliques
usées nettoyé par décapage à très forte
pression c'est le nouveau service
proposé par le site gde groupe ecore de
limay des tuyaux ou d'autres matériaux
notamment en acier ou en fonte
revêtu de substances dangereuses comme
l'amiante des produits entrent ici
emballé sont dans une atmosphère
contrôlée
donc ça veut dire qu'il n'ya aucune
fibre qui peut sortir à l'extérieur de
l'installation et on arrive dans la
salle de traitement salles blanches ou
des opérateurs
qui paie en atmosphère contrôlée en
ventilation assistée traite par ultra
haute pression 2500 barre en décapant
les produits ça c'est la cuve de tampon
qui récupère les autres process
après le traitement et le passage dans
les filtres et qui va être réutilisés
dans le système une fois décontaminer
les produits sont réutilisés par ses
clients la nouvelle unité par décapage
un investissement de 500 mille euros et
4 personnes embauchées spécialisée dans
le recyclage gde traite près de 3,7
millions de tonnes de matières par an en
fait nos clients nous ont demandé de
trouver des solutions à leurs
problématiques environnementales et
économiques puisque jusqu'à présent ces
tuyaux étaient enfouis et donc nous
client avait des coûts d'enfouissement
très importante la capacité de
traitement est environ 200 tonnes par
mois donc 1200 tonnes à l'année et c'est
un investissement dont le retour est
espéré sur une durée inférieure à trois
ans ali mais cet outil s'ajoute au
broyeur de six mille chevaux avec une
capacité de 200 mille tonnes par an et
notamment des véhicules recyclés
l'entreprise est présente sur 64 sites
en france et 11 en europe l espace 50
ans organise demain un forum emploi il
se déroulera de 11h 30 à 16 heures au
sein du centre commercial de montigny le
bretonneux des enseignes comme carrefour
histoire d'or ou encore un mcdonald's
proposeront une vingtaine de postes
commis vendeurs conseillers de clientèle
ou encore manager écouté le directeur du
centre commercial au micro de mélanie
poquet un centre commercial pour nous
n'est pas qu'un lieu de de shopping
c'est aussi un vecteur de dynamisme
économique
dans lequel s'inscrit notamment l'emploi
nous souhaitons favoriser l'insertion
professionnelle et notamment
l'emploi local forum emploi ce jeudi au
centre commercial espace saint quentin
anne capio est avec moi sur ce plateau
bonsoir ça vous êtes la 2è maire-adjoint
d'elancourt en charge de l'éducation de
l'école numérique et du périscolaire
alors la ville participent vendredi à la
codi week c'est une semaine dédiée aux
codes et à la programmation numérique
présentez-nous déjà 7
cette semaine c'est une semaine qui se
déroule au niveau européen c'est ça
voilà c'est ça c'est là qu'au douik est
donc un programme européen de codage
informatique qui s'inscrit à elancourt
dans un programme d'école numérique
globale que nous développons déjà depuis
dix ans nous avons depuis dix ans dans
les écoles distribué une centaine de
robots aussi bien en élémentaire qu'en
maternelle la la codp week est un
programme européen que nous avons monté
en partenariat avec l'organisme de
formation simplon qui est un organisme
de formation sur le codage informatique
mais plutôt dans la formation
professionnelle
donc là ce sont avec simplon pardon on
construit à saint quentin en yvelines le
campus numérique pour développer le
numérique dans les apprentissages des
jeunes et l'inde donc on va avoir une
vingtaine de formateurs de simples ans
qui vont se déployer dans nos écoles ça
ça concerne environ 300 enfants dans nos
dix écoles dès le lancement se défend de
cm2
et là ça va changer un petit peu jusqu'à
maintenant ils apprenaient à coder pour
programmer des robots là ils vont
apprendre à coder pour créer une
application numérique
donc c'est intéressant pour eux puisque
ça développe d'autres compétences que le
codage des robots pourquoi s'associer à
cet événement européen pourrait donc en
vous le disiez c'est ça ça va dans le
sens finalement de l'école numérique
les écoliers exactement ça va ça va dans
notre projet global d'école numérique le
codage informatique est une compétence
primordial selon le c d e
nous ça fait dix ans qu'on l'a compris à
elancourt on essaie décès mais ce projet
un petit peu partout sur les vies
saint quentin et autour je sais que la
ville de bois d'arcy participent
également à cette co douik cette année
et quand on sait que le développement du
codage informatique développe chez les
enfants des compétences qui sont dans
les apprentissages du français de la
mathématique des mathématiques des
sciences même du sport ou de la culture
c'est important de pouvoir s'adapter aux
l'appétence des enfants pour le
numérique pour les aider à apprendre ça
leur apporte concrètement des
connaissances pour le reste de leur s de
leur parcours scolaire
absolument et ça développe l'esprit de
collaboration il travaille entre eux ils
essayent se trompe mais c'est pas grave
ils peuvent recommencer
ils travaillent en groupe ils sont plus
créatifs et et arriva à produire des
choses on est étonné de jour en jour
vous disiez le codage pour les aider
l'encours ils le font depuis plusieurs
années il ya cette école du numérique
un chiffre à donner de 1500 tablette qui
équipe les élèves d'elancourt pourquoi
c'est pour une en cours une importance a
une importance capitale de dalé danse
numérique dans ce développement
numérique pour les basques
le numérique c'est les métiers de demain
on rappelle souvent que à ce jour il y à
50% des métiers qui n'existent pas
encore et qui existeront au moment où
nous et nos enfants qui sont
actuellement à l'école primaire seront
sur le marché du travail donc
aujourd'hui le numérique est partout il
doit être aussi dans l'école bien
évidemment et quand on voit que ça
développe tout un tas de compétences qui
ne pourraient pas être développer
autrement voilà et on organise aussi
depuis quatre ans kai robe qui est un
robotique voilà et kaki qui réunit les
douze villes et même élargi autour de
saint quentin en yvelines ça fait quatre
ans qu'on organise ce challenge et
l'année dernière ça est réuni 1000
enfants et cette année on espère en
faire participer davantage
et quand on voit l'appétence des enfants
ils ont des étoiles dans les yeux ils
réussissent et quoi de mieux dans la vie
de faire réussir un enfant on rappelle
juste qu'il nous reste une minute le
concrètement comment ça va se dérouler
la journée de vendredi ses formes et ses
formateurs pardon vont aller dans les
écoles élan courtoise voilà ils sont ils
sont répartis sur l'ensemble des dix
écoles
ils sont en binôme de deux et ils vont
apprendre pendant une heure ou deux aux
enfants à développer une application sur
sur tablette
on a chargé sur l'ensemble des 2500
tablette une logiciel qui s'appelle
swift programme et qu'il a donc les
aider à développer et on a développé
cette application sur l'ensemble des
deux mille tablait dès 2500 tablettes
parce qu'on espère que après cet cette
opération coup de poing on va dire
les autres écoles auront envie d'y
participer après et cette conne week
elancourt je rappelle qu'elles se
déroulent donc ce vendredi merci alkio
d'avoir été avec nous disent en friche
rappelle que vous êtes deuxième maire
adjointe d'elancourt en charge de
l'éducation de l'école numérique et du
périscolaire
cette commune elle est souvent distingué
pour ses espaces naturels bonne elle a
reçu le prix ile de france de l' agence
régionale de la biodiversité récompensé
pour sa politique de longue date de
préservation de son patrimoine naturel
un travail mené notamment sur la réserve
naturelle des étangs de bonnel le
village est également honoré pour son
plan à zéro pesticide
allez on se met à l'heure américaine
pour terminer ce journal durant un mois
une chef de la filiale de sodexo aux
états unis va parcourir l'hexagone avec
20 recettes à partager première étape
cette semaine au siège du groupe
français à guyancourt marylène iapichino
a pu observer est les préparations la
toque est différente et les habitudes
culinaires aussi qu'il écrirait few ce
travail chez sodexo à atlanta aux etats
unis elle est venue partager son savoir
faire avec les chefs français du groupe
nous allons passer les côtelettes à la
poêle en les saisissant et on aura une
belle caramélisation du port le groupe
sodexo va lancer ce programme global
chef il ya douze ans l'idée de profiter
de sa présence dans 80 pays pour faire
voyager les chefs et mélanger les
saveurs
quand ils viennent ils viennent avec
leur envie leur esprit leur approche
culinaire leurs recettes que nous
restions ensemble au restaurant de façon
à partager avec eux leur univers est
vraiment l'origine de leur pays
côtelettes de porc risotto de butternut
kelly griffe youth a ramené 20 recettes
qu'elle va transmettre au chef français
elle se nourrit également de la culture
culinaire de l'hexagone qu'elle visite
pour la première fois je dois travailler
que certains grands chefs français que
je n'avais jamais vu encore donc c'est
très excitant
j'apprends que le monde de la
restauration est énorme mais il ya
beaucoup de choses qui sont similaires
avec ce qu'on fait nous donc c'est
génial
depuis trois ans que la fidl françaises
participent cinq autres chefs de pays
différents sont déjà venus mais des
chefs français partent aussi apporter
quiche lorraine et cassoulet outre
atlantique sébastien mme allard a visité
le nord des états unis ainsi qu'une
partie du canada montré à l'ado pays
notre culture notre façon de faire nos
recettes
et puis surtout de pouvoir voir leur
façon aussi de travailler parce que
c'est totalement différent qui déboulait
fils va poursuivre son séjour dans toute
la france certaines de ces recettes se
retrouveront ensuite au menu des
restaurants du groupe
c'est la fin du set 8 journal belle
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]